what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and things are super
exciting in the mcu right now
specifically because marvel revealed all
of their face five and some of their
phase six and phase five and phase six
so far look awesome however i think
we're in for a really big treat in phase
seven and yes that is a little bit away
however i think this is the phase that
most fans have been truly waiting for
from the specific projects to the heroes
and to the villains that we will get in
phase seven and beyond i believe that
phase seven will be the prime phase for
marvel studios and i'll explain why and
we'll talk about how phase six is going
to end and set up phase seven
specifically in regards to the fantastic
four the x-men and the new big bads that
are coming now phase one through four
and upcoming phase five and six have all
been about primarily avengers with the
guardians of the galaxy who i include
when i say avengers because they fought
in avengers end game for the most part
all of the stories revolved around an
avenger or a guardian even if they
weren't an avenger at the time they
would eventually go on to become an
avenger spider-man goes on to become an
avenger t'challa goes on to play a huge
part in avengers infinity war and end
game and this is all marvel really could
do because they didn't have the rights
to the x-men or the fantastic four at
the time to introduce these other groups
however since the fox acquisition disney
now owns all of these characters and now
they have the ability to include all of
these other groups and this is where
phase 6 comes in however we are not
going to see the full potential of the
fantastic four or mutant x-men in phase
six we're only going to kind of be
teased with them yes the fantastic four
and the x-men are going to be a part of
secret wars i really don't think marvel
studios could do a secret wars without
having the mutants there and without
having the fantastic four however the
fantastic four are going to be released
late 2024 and the last avengers film
avengers secret wars comes out late 2025
that means the fantastic four will have
only been in the mcu for a year and if
they put the x-men somewhere in phase 6
the x-men won't have even been in the
mcu for a year before we get to secret
wars but here's why this is actually a
good thing there are 5 major reasons why
phase 7 is going to completely blow away
any other phase that we've got so far in
the mcu and this starts with the end of
phase six it's a good thing that the
x-men and the fantastic four are only
going to be introduced at the end of
phase six because that means it's just
going to be a little tease of who they
actually are we'll have one movie about
the fantastic four and maybe the mutants
will appear in a couple of projects then
they will team up and they will fight in
secret wars however like i said this is
just a tease a glimpse of what the
fantastic four can do and who the
mutants are actually going to be because
i don't believe they will introduce a
lot of mutants before secret wars there
are a lot of spots in phase 6 but we
already know a lot of the films or
projects that are going to be coming out
like armor wars or deadpool or nova
projects that have already been
announced but don't have official
release dates are most likely going to
fill these slots of phase 6 which means
we'll probably only get one or two
projects with the mutants in them so
phase 6 and the multiverse saga ends
with a slight introduction to the
fantastic four and the mutants and then
in phase seven is where we pick up and
we get really introduced to them so
reasons one and two of the five points
of why phase seven is going to blow us
away are the x-men and the fantastic
four of course but really diving into
who they actually are really diving into
bigger stories and most importantly the
connectivity that the mcu offers we will
have individual mutant projects and
x-men projects that will focus on
specific characters but also
interconnect with other x-men projects
with other fantastic four projects and
of course still avengers projects and of
course the same goes for the fantastic
four they will interact with other x-men
and they will interact with other
avengers however reed richards is going
to be a very important and pivotal
character of phase seven why well
because he is the smartest man alive and
he is going to be a crucial component in
beating the next big bad of the next
saga which is going to be galactus which
is actually 0.4 and not 0.3 0.3 is one
of galactus's heralds which i'm assuming
is going to be the silver server now of
course we've gotten a silver surfer
movie before the fantastic four the rise
of the silver surfer so there is always
the thought that marvel studios might
want to stay away from the silver surfer
for a while and introduce another
fantastic four villain however we are
expecting dr doom to appear in the mcu
quite soon and we know that he'll
probably play a major role in secret
wars and could even be the main villain
on top of king giving us god emperor
doom but having said that i do not
believe that he's going to be done in
phase six i think he's going to continue
on in the mcu at least i hope but point
three of why phase seven is going to be
awesome is cause we are going to be
introduced to a herald of galactus and i
hope it's the silver surfer now here's
where reed richards and the fantastic
four come in they're going to come in
contact with the silver surfer but i
think most of us know how that story
goes ultimately the silver surfer is
typically convinced that earth is worth
saving and defies galactus he then works
alongside the fantastic four and other
heroes who will be in the mcu at that
point in time to defeat galactus but
this is going to be a huge event
galactus is going to be the kang or the
doom of phase 7 and phase 8 and maybe
even phase 9. depending on how long they
want to take it but galactus will be the
big bad of the next saga which could be
the galactus saga i've seen a lot of fan
art out there that says the age of
galactus and i really like that title
now galactus has been defeated many
different times in the comics and
sometimes it's not even that hard
literally squirrel girl defeated him
well not really defeated him but kept
him from consuming the earth by simply
being his friend and giving him some
nuts no i don't think that's going to
happen in the mcu of course i think it's
ultimately going to come down to the
ultimate nullifier most comic book fans
know what this is it's the ultimate
weapon that can defeat galactus and it's
actually kept on galactus ship however
in the mcu i think reed richards in the
fantastic four and maybe even some other
smart people like bruce banner if he's
still around will be the ones to create
the ultimate nullifier however i also
believe that there is one more point
that is going to make phase seven and
beyond pretty epic and that is the
cosmic entities now galactus himself is
a cosmic entity he's a cosmic being and
marvel studios recently has kind of been
preparing us for cosmic beans they
mentioned the living tribunal in doctor
strange we actually saw the living
tribunal and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and they
introduced eternity in thor love and
thunder however eternity was very
different than his comic counterpart but
even though the cosmic entities might be
a little bit different i do believe
they'll have some major roles to play in
phase 7 and beyond which i hope
ultimately leads up to some avengers
x-men and fantastic four kind of teaming
up with some cosmic entities we know the
watcher exists in the mcu we saw the
statue of the watcher in thor love and
thunder and in guardians of the galaxy 2
they showed us some watchers talking to
our man stan lee rest in peace and in
the comic books although the watcher is
not supposed to interfere he often times
does in fact he's kind of the one who
tells the fantastic four about the
ultimate nullifier and that it's on
galactus ship in the comics so secret
wars and the king dynasty are going to
be pretty epic but i think we're in for
a real treat when it comes down to
fighting galactus because it's going to
take literally everybody including some
cosmic beans now i say some cosmic
beings because some cosmic entities out
there choose to actually not interfere
with galactus take eternity for example
eternity considers galactus a part of
the natural order of the universe which
is why eternity doesn't interfere with
galactus devouring worlds i'm sure there
are some other cosmic entities that
might feel the same take the living
tribunal for example when issuing
judgment all three heads have to agree
if only two heads agree and one doesn't
they will not execute a judgment or
interfere however i do believe there are
other cosmic entities like the watcher
and like some celestials who will
interfere the celestials are big ones
because galactus devours worlds and as
we've learned the worlds are kind of
cocoons for unborn celestials who feed
off of the energy of the population that
lives on the planet and the eternals
made a pretty big deal about how
important this is to the celestials how
important it is for other celestials to
be born because eventually they go on to
create other worlds so they would
probably have an issue with galactus
going around and destroying their worlds
that they're creating some housing
unborn celestials so i know secret wars
is going to be epic and the greatest
thing that we've got from marvel studios
so far however i think the x-men and the
fantastic four are going to be even more
involved in phase seven and beyond and i
do believe galactus is coming after
phase six as well so based off of what
we know phase six will be kang and doom
then we'll have secret wars and a bunch
of different variants which is going to
be an epic battle but then after that
we'll get more focus on the fantastic
four the x-men the cosmic entities and
galactus will come and hopefully the
silver surfer his herald comes before
him and joins the fight i think this
would be the best saga that we've got so
far from the mcu granted we haven't
finished phase five and six yet and i do
believe they're going to be epic but i
think phase seven and beyond are going
to be even more epic but let me know
what you think about all of this in the
comments down below what do you think
we'll see in phase seven don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof